[Music]
in february nasa's newest mars rover
perseverance landed on the red planet
[Music]
confirmed
faithfully on the surface of mars
ready to
but the meat of the mission is just
beginning
for the first time ever scientists are
bringing back material from another
planet these samples will help planetary
scientists answer one of the most
important scientific and existential
questions
is there life outside earth
but one surprising key to this mission
it can't be done without these six-inch
titanium tubes
there are 43 of these tubes on
perseverance that rover is now trucking
through jezera crater gathering chalk
sized samples in the tubes it's already
drilled and collected its first samples
this is jezreel crater it's important
because it's an area that was once home
to an ancient river delta
and where there's water there's usually
life
nasa spend billions on the whole
perseverance operation though the tubes
don't look like much it took the agency
about a decade to develop them
every detail was thought out just look
at this intricate system aboard the
rover that houses them once they're
filled the tubes will be among the most
important packages in planetary science
rivaling the containers from the apollo
program that brought home chunks of the
moon and more recent ones with asteroid
samples in short these little tubes are
a big deal so what makes them so out of
this world and why did nasa spend so
much time developing them
explico
the tubes are mission critical because
once they're shipped back to earth the
samples they will hold will be the first
new completely uncontaminated martian
rocks that scientists will get their
hands on
ever
the ones they have easy access to right
now were found in antarctica by a team
of meteorite hunters starting in the
1970s that's me holding one of them the
rocks have been sitting there for
thousands if not millions of years and
scientists don't know where on mars they
came from or what their journey to the
ice was like plus there aren't a lot of
them
so to really know if there's life
outside of earth nasa needs rocks that
are 100
mars
so
what's the solution
limpia
extreme cleanliness
to eliminate even the faintest traces of
material that hints at earthly life
because on earth
we are absolutely surrounded in a just
thick thick soup of carbon organic
material that's ian clark he's a systems
engineer who's been working on the tubes
for years he and his colleagues at
nasa's jet propulsion laboratory are
taking cleaning to a whole new level at
jpl we built an entirely new clean room
uh cleaner than any of the clean rooms
that we've ever used for our spacecraft
in the past in the super clean room
engineers went to town on the tubes they
blasted them with ultra pure air rinse
them with the ionized water and cleaned
them with exotic cleaning agents and
high-grade acetone
yep that's the stuff we use to remove
our nail polish but you know in a much
purer form and once wasn't always enough
ian told me that sometimes they had to
do this process over and over again we
would start to do something we would
send it to the chemistry lab to get
measured they'd come back and say not
clean enough clean enough meant that
there couldn't be more than 150
nanograms or billionths of a gram of
organic carbon on each of the tubes so
just how little is that that is about a
single very very very very fine grain of
sand there were also lower limits for
certain kinds of carbon containing
compounds like dna which is the genetic
code for life to make sure the samples
stay pristine the engineers created a
kind of contamination shield by treating
the titanium tubes in a special way
its advantage after the treatment unlike
regular titanium things don't stick to
the surface as much they kind of just
slide off and to catch any molecules
that do manage to stay on there's yet
another barrier it's basically a
high-tech carbon contamination sucking
sponge made of crushed sapphires why
would we want to have a sponge of
contamination on the tube well
we really don't want contamination
inside the tube where the sample will be
but if there's something that's
traveling its way there if we can catch
it and keep it constrained before it
finds its way inside the sample tube
then we much prefer to do that mars can
get super hot so the crystal sponge will
also help the samples with temperature
control
engineers want to keep the temperatures
inside the tubes cool that way the
rock's chemistry isn't altered over the
many years the tubes will be sitting on
the surface of mars all the tubes
components need to be strong and durable
because after that long wait is over
there's a whole other intricate part of
the mission too the journey back to
earth since the perseverance rover can't
fly and bring the tubes back to earth on
its own a lander carrying another rover
will go to mars that new rover will
gather the samples and bring them back
to the lander the tubes will be loaded
onto a rocket that will shoot them into
mars orbit the tubes will be inside a
special container meanwhile another
spacecraft will be sent to orbit mars
that spacecraft will collect the martian
samples and start a month-long trip back
to earth it's
one of the most complicated challenging
uh and certainly exciting endeavors that
i think we as a species have ever
undertaken so yeah that's going to take
some time for now the tubes aren't
scheduled to come back to earth until
2031 but that's only every little thing
goes exactly as planned and if nasa and
the european space agency get the
funding for the sample return missions
well it's time to end this mission but
if you're interested in mars or space in
general i've left some links down below
for you and don't forget to hit
subscribe so you don't miss what we
explore next hasta luego nos vemos
pronto gracias
[Music]
you